alors paul vi ça veut dire pôle de vie
faire qu'on est une association qui
travaillons pour développer un pôle de
vie pour toutes les personnes qui
travaillent sur le plateau de saclay les
fondateurs de paul devine sont au nombre
de sept
donc il ya thales horiba le c2 n le cea
l'afrique est une association de
formation d'apprentis soleil et puis
danone
depuis sa fondation paul vi c'est
beaucoup a grandi avec l'adhésion de
nouveaux employeurs ou de nouvelles
entreprises et aujourd'hui on a une
trentaine de membres qui sont à la fois
des grandes entreprises des start up et
aussi un certain nombre de centres de
recherche liés à des écoles ou à
l'université
car ils sont tous employeurs de
personnes dans la qui travaillent sur le
plateau de saclay l'association continue
de grandir et donc nous avons chaque
jour de nouveaux membres qui vont se
joindre à nous les membres de
l'association paul vi sairgroup à peu
près trente mille postes de travail on a
je voulais des beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dans nos entreprises
ces personnels doivent se déplacer elles
doivent vivre sur le plateau et doivent
se loger nos grands projets nos grands
axes de travail aujourd'hui c'est les
transports en commun donc l'arrivée
future de la ligne 18 ou sera t-elle
comment va-t-elle desservir notre
plateau mais aussi comment va-t-on vivre
et se déplacer en attendant l'arrivée de
la ligne 18 le deuxième grand sujet
c'est les services créés sur le plateau
des espaces de restauration et de
détente pour nos salariés et enfin nous
travaillons aussi sur les questions de
logement pour que voilà les gens qui
travaillent dans nos entreprises
puissent habiter à proximité
en agissant ensemble évidemment on est
plus fort et plus efficace que si
chacune de ces entreprises essaye d'agir
par ses propres moyens
on veut favoriser les conditions de vie
sur le plateau et ça évidemment ça va
attirer de nouvelles entreprises
on peut dire indirectement voilà qu'on
est là aussi pour créer tout un
écosystème favorable à l'emploi